DON'T PANIC, CELTICS NATION.
HE'S NOT THE NEXT ONE, MARK
JACKSECOND
UNIT HE HAS A CASE.
FINISHING WI
HIM.
MAKING THINGS HARD FOR DONOVAN.
>> Craig: INSIDE AND PUSHES LOO
ON HOLDING
CALL ON PRITCHARD.
>> JEFF GREENVERYTHING WITH
THAT.
>> Matt: BARNES TURNS THE
CORNER, OH!
AND BARNES PICKED IT RIGHT BACK
UP.
GETTING TO THEJAREN
>> LOOK FOROVER.
NICE HELP BY SATORANSKY.
IS
ISH SMITH PICKING UP THE LOOSE
BALL, GOT
THESE, THE ROCKETS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SEE THE THERE
BY ACTUALLY SHOOTING THE THREE.
>>> STAY TUNED O
STRONG.
NICE BLOCKOUT BY GIVING HIM
A STANDING OVATION RIGHT NOW.
>> Craig: WIT INSIDE THE
DOTTED, A FLY BY  IS LIKELY WHY
THAT SHOT WENT IN.
>> RIDING UP HIGH, A COUNTING T
>> Walt: SO USE THAT FORD A
DAGGER WHEN RANDLE THRTHE MIDDL
OF THAT DEFENSE.
CHUMA JUMP UP THE GAME NAIL, CO
THIS BABY IN OVERTIME.
TWO-POINT LAKER LEAD.
ISH SMITH
>>> YOUR FRIEND.
YOU CANNOT HAVE  ANY WAISTED
POSSESSIONS HERE BUT LOOK AT
>> IF YOU WANTANCE
COMES OVER OUT, AND
TREY -- TO TREY CAN PUT THIS
BASKETBALL ON THE FLOOR AND IT'
TOP-SHOT RIGHT THERE.